I'm here with Richard serrouter head of
Deborah Richard thank you for chatting
with us amazing job in the keynote thank
you so much so many cool things coming
out from the developer keynote um I'm
really curious though specifically about
duet AI of course are there any
hidden Gems or maybe things that we're
not talking about as much that we can
share with people you know I think some
of the chat integration everywhere is
really cool whether you're a bigquery
you're in just the console and it just
the way we use that it's maybe a little
unexpected that it's not just asking
questions it can explain a query for you
they can do all kinds of things so I
think it's pretty wild the chat's all
over the place and it can be helpful in
just many different ways so is there any
specific chat in one place that you like
the best I like the bigquery when I ask
you to explain a query it can kick it
right as a chance how we won the world
that query does that surprised me when I
first used it so I was like that's a
that's a cool way to take advantage of
it besides duet AI what else are you
really excited about that you've seen it
next
and even some of the uh the Gen app
builder some of the like I don't know
about you I'm not like a data scientist
so when I can look at these tools and I
can actually build some of these apps
and it's just more simple and you don't
have to be an expert in everything to do
something good that seems awesome I'm
just excited that all of us normal
humans can actually create awesome stuff
with this yeah absolutely I totally
agree end users kind of like becoming
able to do more things okay well thank
you so much Richard maybe well have some
new hidden gems coming out here and
there who knows thank you I appreciate
you talking to us and have a great rest
of your time here thank you